meanwhile the families of people who've
been affected by the controversial
hormone pregnancy drug primados have
been refused permission to take their
case to court more than 200 campaigners
began the legal action after using the
drug between the 50s and the 70s
claiming it caused serious birth defects
our home editor Jason Farrell joins us
now from Central London a bitter
disappointment for campaigners Jason
yeah I've spoken to some of the families
and they are disappointed with this
ruling they had hoped that they would be
able to get this to court and argue
their case in front of a full uh hearing
but this has been struck out
um by Mrs Justice Yip I think really on
two grounds one is that she feels that
the science hasn't progressed enough to
prove their case and secondly they don't
have the funds to actually take this
case uh to court she said I recognize
the profound disappointment my judgment
will bring for the claimants they
believe and will no doubt continue to
believe that htps hpts that's hormone
pregnancy tests were the cause of birth
defects and the loss of babies which
they have suffered and no one has been
able to confirm definitively that this
belief is wrong the claimants do not
believe Justice was done in 1982 and
they have fought hard to seek Justice
since but what she says is since that
original claim back in 1982 it's simply
the the evidence hasn't moved forward
enough for them to have a realistic
chance of success in this case now I
think it's the you know it's important
to stress it's understandable that Bayer
the manufacturer in this case would try
to defend and pick holes in their case
and defend their reputation and defend
their shareholders I think there is more
of a gray area over the role of the
government here who've stood alongside
the manufacturers against the claimants
because of course three years ago they
apologized to the claimers for failing
them following a review that the
government itself ordered by baroness
cumblage which found that there was
avoidable harm caused by these drugs as
well as mesh and valparate and the
government was asked to apologize and
they did Apologize here Matt Hancock
made that apology and he described it as
a scandal and I think the the claimants
in this case will say well why then is
the government using tax taxpayers money
to fund a legal claim that eventually
essentially defend ends the reputation
of a German pharmaceutical company
and stops them the families that the
government apologized to from having
their day in court and and they will say
that that's not a particularly a good
look for the government and I think it
means that now from from speaking to
them they're not going to go away
they're going to continue to come to the
government for compensation because they
feel that the cumbers review showed that
they were failed by Regulators it stated
quite clearly that the drugs should have
been removed from the market back in
1967 but it stayed on the market for
eight or nine years longer than that in
which time they feel a lot of babies
were damaged they've not been able to
prove that conclusively in court they
won't get the opportunity to do so but I
think they will still come for the
government and say to them they've
they've been told to give compensation
redress to these victims and actually
they've stopped them having their day in
court but now it's time to perhaps
assist and help this group of disabled
campaigners
Jason thank you